à l'information du jour c'est qu'on est
bientôt la fin de l'année scolaire
donc c'est chouette il reste plus que
deux jours
des séances de cinéma en plein air le
point commun entre le PSG et la
Promenade des Anglais les prénoms les
plus donnés dans le département c'est au
programme de cette pause info du 5
juillet
le nouveau campus du PSG à Poissy est
présenté aujourd'hui à la presse mais
saviez-vous qu'il existe un point commun
entre ce site de 74 hectares et la
Promenade des Anglais à Nice c'est son
concepteur Jean-Michel Wilmotte
l'architecte designer est à l'origine
des célèbres chaises bleues qui font
face à la Méditerranée et il est donc
également le concepteur de ce nouveau
site d'entraînement du club de la
capitale terrain de sport bâtiment
administratif centre médical musée des
conditions optimum pour accueillir les
joueurs et pourquoi pas remporter Ligue
des Champions
si vous résidez dans les Yvelines que
vous êtes jeune parents peut-être
avez-vous prénommé votre enfant Emma ou
Gabriel ce sont les deux prénoms
féminins et masculins les plus donnés
dans le département selon une enquête de
l'INSEE au niveau national jade Louise
ou Léo ont également le vent en poupe en
revanche Yvelines a complètement disparu
et ce depuis 1988 à cette époque on ne
comptait au niveau national que 11
petites filles à s'appeler ainsi
vous pouvez d'ores et déjà noter les
dates dans vos agendas du 18 août 9
septembre se déroulera la douzième
édition des Yvelines font leur cinéma
pilotés par le Conseil départemental des
Yvelines qui vient de dévoiler la
programmation les tuches 3 Top Gun
Maverick au total 68 lieux de
programmation pour se retrouver en
famille ou entre amis première séance le
18 août à Mantes-la-Ville avec le
deuxième volet de Tous en scène le
dessin animé musical
dans des plaies au touristes le château
de Versailles ne sera pas présenté dans
son plus bel écran pendant les prochains
mois mais c'est pour mieux briller alors
de l'ouverture des jeux olympiques en
2024 la grille d'honneur est recouverte
d'une palissade en bois datant du XVIIe
siècle elle sera rénovée consolidée
s'offrira à une nouvelle dorure
rappelons que la ville royale
accueillera les épreuves à d'équitation
et de pentathlon